it's time for roses and Rosie with Wells
oh my god round of applause from our
very small crew Wells Adams is here
applauding himself good job well for
showing up on time made it here I did
it's nice about that's what it's about
on The Bachelor and here at roses and
roses a cheers to you Cheers
oh my gosh okay so we got these like
old-fashioned glasses cuz like I feel
like you're an old school guy look at
this jacket you're wearing what an
unbelievable backdrop for her to
continue to develop relationship with me
you guys we've been following along
we're at Episode five and Wells is here
we're gonna watch it they're in London
they are how's your Finnish accent
so it's all right I suppose it's good
good sorry London bloody nailing it
nothing nothing says nothing says love
like fish and chips where were you in
2012 I was in Nashville okay
on the radio that was a couple years out
of college already on the radio already
on the radio telling it yeah yes to be
honest with you I was more successful
and now it's been it's been downhill
what I first want to show you is this
hilarious moment where Chris Harrison is
explaining the date to the guy the guys
only Tim love you well there's are
either shine of you he is physically so
far from them like because everyone has
the same haircut in 2012 people are
really excited about the like redhead
gel people said that every banjo Josie
is now the same haircut you were really
good definitely I hope it comes out here
we go you ready
what's up she goes on a one-on-one with
Sean Lowe now let me ask you have you
ever met Wow I have what I'm what I
can't figure out during this is what can
go wrong with Sean she's like he's so
confident he's so hot he's passionate
he's honest like this done pretty good
on the checklist of what I'm everything
he says he's not really good on the
checklist confident he has the same
haircut as everyone else here I love him
what do you think of Sean Lowe like in
real life yes I think that he's amazing
on Twitter oh Romeo Romeo where for our
thought y'all Romeo they go on a date
involving Shakespeare because you know
they're in England and I'm a bachelor
they do think it's completely
quintessential to wherever they're yeah
so it's this Shakespeare date where the
guys are gonna have to act things out
well we'll play this little clip so you
can kind of get introduced to the moment
Ari is in a word and two words scared
begin shitless why he doesn't act I hate
acting so you're gonna have to act like
you like 26 people in a couple weeks
buddy I am really looking forward to all
these guys performing some Shakespeare
today I think it's gonna be really funny
yikes what's the wig I always never over
thought anything no that's why I took
him five years ago hmm did you think it
was gonna be Peter there was talk for a
while would be you know there wasn't to
be fifth there was talk from a few
select people there were people that
wanted that to happen I was not one of
them so were you asked to do and you
said no yeah they asked me to do it and
I said no because it's a dating show and
I like someone else
so it's good you like someone else's
movie so you are happy in this
relationship that you're in and things
are good everything's really good
that's amazing yeah okay I thought it
wasn't me Peter for sure and he would've
been a good one I know oh I know oh wow
who doesn't like the Sun hasn't set on
that dream for me of course not
next up we are going to see what you
have
about re the kissing bandit I also want
to call him the blanket bandit because
literally every time he sees her it's
like he's got a blanket to wrap around
her shoulders yeah you just make her
feel so that's how you know you're gonna
make it far in the show if they give you
stuff like that wait they never gave me
any of that wait what like a prop is
that an indicator if they were like hey
here's a blanket she might hurt the
shoulders might be cold and you're like
oh that's good why didn't you ask for
something wrong I don't know I was just
happy I was there I was just like I
don't know why I'm still here guys I'm
just excited to be a boy god I just
remembered a completely forgotten about
that
Watergate you went on so it was so
cringe-worthy the good old days the good
old days only 17 months ago okay
so let's take this okay everyone is so
shiny this season I can't get over it
did they blot you if they thought you
know never my shiny right now no but me
I guess you weren't prioritized what was
that stay with this kid for paradise
he'll be great give us a muppet okay
here comes the kiss he's cuddling her
blankets hands oh yeah there it is
listen bandit take notes he was a
salt-and-pepper like a silver fox back
already
yeah I know and this was in 98 this was
in 72 huh he always holds her face do
you hold a face that's a good move
no I think maybe back of the neck okay I
do it to myself just to feel good yeah
yeah for so long but what I like about
her and Ari is that when she's with him
they kind of have these little little
mini exchanges like he'll under his
breath okay my goodness it's like dude
the mics still here you you know
whatever like did people ever in
Paradise bachelor whatever
did you see moments that felt like they
were real like maybe people were like
hoping the cameras weren't on or like
this is actually a real moment you know
the one I remember for me I think it was
Newton the roasts the first rose
ceremony I remember she she kept on like
screwing up so they would
kind of pull her aside and be like this
is this guy's yeah I think that's
exactly right
she gave me her Amy of Rose or whatever
yeah pretty early to like I was I felt
pretty comfortable that night and I
remember like whispering into her ear
we're sharing all the stories yeah this
is great I thought this is what this was
this not what this was
yeah and I said I said you got this girl
because I think says she was like
stressing out about it but they didn't
hear that
do you see you all's thanks that's a
nice skin thing to say yeah oh wait you
didn't do it let's do it you serious I'm
not being a single girl okay no right do
you know Jeff Holman yeah I've met him
once Jeff 1/f yeah what was your thought
brief interaction nice guy don't know
what you think he had hit hair from my
season Jeff was a freaking wizard there
on the London Eye she's telling him so
she picks this guy right she picks him
he looks like a kid 12 yeah the most by
the way I'll never why if you ever asked
me anything I'll never lie to you I get
better um I feel why sure there's the
most important thing here I'll joke
around a lot but I want every why what
if she says how does this make me look
fat
then you should you got a lot that's a
that's a no always lie well it it
doesn't sound like something that you
would say to someone that you were in
love with or falling in love with it
sounds like something that you would say
to someone that you're like trying to
make them feel better about their
situation
so it's interesting is this episode and
we don't even have time to get into it
you got flying on your screen proud of
you what else is bang Cheers
I really I caught it it's fine you guys
wanna play today
wells came to play it's night one a
Bachelorette no one may have a little
bit more don't do it over the computer
you crazy person oh I think if anyone's
proved that they have
together today it's me to do yeah so
you've got it this is the island of
misfit interviews right here
I didn't hear I didn't come here to go
on group dates out there like ya came
here to hang out with their addictions
you gotta realize if you become part of
her life pretty much any day it's gonna
be a group date it's gonna be you her
and Ricky this guy Kalyn called her
daughter Ricki baggage and she is mad at
like everyone including Jeff because she
and Jeff had the conversation with him
because nobody told her that he called
Ricki baggage for like a couple days I
think that that's kind of harsh though
cuz like I don't know did you feel like
if a guy says something you were gonna
like go tell no you know what I mean
much I remember going to show him my
sister had one rule if she was like
never go against other guy and never go
tattle it always works bad for them yeah
you know I've tried to concentrate so
much on us that I try not to like get
caught up in what other people say
basically she's mad at everybody for not
tattling on the sky Aria is worried he's
not gonna get a rose and guess what Arie
gets a rose and that's pretty much the
episode in a nutshell or at least all we
were here today when this week we're
still clean I'm trying to go I was a
bartender I'm trying to clean things up
here full circle we have no wine left I
think this is a good place to edge
that's because I spilled it all over my
crotch thank you so much for being here
guys make sure to follow Wells on social
media and listen to his podcast your
favorite thing yeah with brandy Cyrus we
talked about our favorite things but
really don't yeah great I mean it's like
it's like will let's do it right now
real quick okay what's your favorite
thing this week I'm Taylor Swift's new
album really yeah favorite song on your
favorite between getaway car and
delicate but I feel like it changes
every day and I feel like I'm in a movie
when I'm listening to that album and it
takes me to a different place
write about it a couple times me Marc do
you love the fact that I've hijacked
your show and started interviewing you
do you love the fact that this is a
great place for you to promote that your
favorite thing podcasts where it turns
out people can't talk about their
favorite things yeah and um I'm gonna
say adopt a dog because I feel that's a
closet very close to your heart so you
know go for rescues because this is what
matters to us is the best person in the
world thank you for being here and I'm
sorry that I spilled
you don't have to be sorry you've done
enough good in the world like et on
Facebook subscribe to us on YouTube
don't say wells for bachelor anymore
because he's a happy person and we love
and we're very happy for him and have a
great day everybody why are you shaking
your head yeah like no I'd only be the
bachelor Oh bye bye
[Music]